HAVE A GOOD NIGHT, EVERYBODY.
TUCKER IS UP NEXT.
WHEN MY GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME
TO "TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
FOR MORE THAN A MONTH, MOBS OF
VIOLENT CRAZY PEOPLE OF ROME TO
THIS COUNTRY TERRORIZING
CITIZENS AND DESTROYING THINGS.
NO ONE HAS STOPPED THEM FROM
DOING THAT SO IT’S CONTINUED
FREEDOM POLITICIANS NOW COWER BE
MOB.
IT ENFORCES THEIR DEMANDS.
POLICE OFFICERS EMASCULATED AND
RESTRAINED, WATCH IT ALL FROM
THE SIDELINES UNABLE TO HELP.
FOR WEEKS, WE’VE ASKED WHO WILL
STAND UP FOR THIS COUNTRY?
AND THE ANSWER AS AMERICANS,
AMERICANS WILL COME IT IS UP TO
THEM.
SMALL GROUPS OF CITIZENS ARE
BEGINNING TO COME FORWARD TO
DEFEND THEIR LAWS IN HISTORY AND
CULTURE.
AND DEEP IT DOES NOT OWN THOSE
THINGS ARE BLACK LIVES MATTER.
THEY HAVE NO RIGHT TO DESTROY
THEM.
A GROUP OF CITIZENS GATHERED TO
DEFEND THE STATUE OF TEDDY
ROOSEVELT.
THE MOST POPULAR PRESIDENT IN
THE HISTORY OF THIS NATION
BECAUSE HE WAS A STERLING MORAL
EXAMPLE.
AND TiVo WANTS HIM ERASED.
LOCAL OFFICIALS SAID THEY WILL
COMPLY WITH THAT DEMAND.
NO ONE ASKED THE PUBLIC WITH THE
PUBLIC THINKS OF THIS.
OUR LEADERS DON’T CARE WHAT THEY
THINK.
THIS GROUP DECIDED TO BE HEARD.
>> YOU FALL SO HARD.
>> GET BACK OVER THERE.
>> WHO ARE YOU TALKING TO?
YOU’VE GOT SOMETHING TO SAY,
LITTLE BOY?
NO, YOU DON’T, DO YOU?
I’LL STAND WHEREVER I WANT.
IS THAT THE BEST YOU’VE GOT,
BABY BOY?
IS THAT THE BEST YOU’VE GOT?
>> Tucker: THAT’S THE NEW YORK
WE LOVE.
IS THAT THE BEST YOU’VE GOT?
ACTUALLY, YES, IT IS THE BEST
THEY’VE GOT.
TURN DOWN THE VOLUME AND YOU SEE
IT VERY CLEARLY.
THE MOB IS NOT FEARSOME, IT’S
PATHETIC.
THESE ARE PAMPERED CHILDREN PLAY
ACTING A REVOLUTION, COWARDS.
THAT’S WHY THEY MOVE IN PACKS.
THEY HAVE NO SKILLS.
ALL THEY CAN DO IS DESTROY
PAIRED THE CLOSER YOU GET TO
THEM, THE CLEARER ALL OF THAT IS
IS.
>> THIS IS NOT ABOUT RACE
ANYMORE.
NEVER REALLY WAS.
THIS IS ABOUT TAKING APART THE
FABRIC OF AMERICA.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
IT NEVER WAS ABOUT RACIAL
JUSTICE.
THE PRESIDENT UNDERSTANDS IT
TOO.
LAST WEEK, HE ISSUED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO PROTECT OUR
MONUMENTS FROM THE MOB.
ON SATURDAY, CHARGED FOR PEOPLE
WITH DESTRUCTION OF FEDERAL
PROPERTY FOR VANDALIZING
MONUMENTS RIGHT ACROSS FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
FEDERAL PARK POLICE POSTED 15
WANTED POSTERS ONLINE.
THE CORPORATE REVOLUTIONARIES
WERE OUTRAGED BY THAT ENFORCING
THE LAW?
ENFORCING THE LAW IS RACIST,
THEY LECTURED US.
MSNBC ANCHORS ENJOY SEEING
STATUES TOPPLE AS THEY GLIDE BY.
MAKES THEM FEEL ALIVE.
>> ANOTHER SIGN OF WHERE HIS
PRIORITIES ARE DURING THIS TIME,
THE PRESIDENT SIGNED A NEW
EXECUTIVE ORDER YESTERDAY
CENTERED ON PROTECTING
MONUMENTS, MEMORIALS, AND
STATUES.
NOT PEOPLE.
>> SO HE THREATENS PRISON TERMS,
THREATENS RETRIBUTION, DEFENDANT
STATUES.
HE IGNORES THE SUBSTANCE OF THE
MESSAGE AND HOLDING MISSES THE
MARK.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER ABOUT THE
PROTESTS, BUT NOT TO PROTECT
PEOPLE DYING AT THE HANDS OF THE
STATE BUT INSTEAD SIGNED AN
ORDER THAT DENOUNCED PROTESTERS
THAT VANDALIZE CIVIL WAR
MONUMENTS PROTECTING STATUES
WELL WILL PEOPLE SUFFER AND SOME
DIED.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE SUCH
LIARS.
CIVIL WAR MONUMENT.
THEY ARE TAKING DOWN STATUES OF
ABRAHAM LINCOLN ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
BUT DID YOU CATCH THE LAST LINE?
WHILE REAL PEOPLE SUFFER.
THEY ARE REAL PEOPLE.
THEY LIVE IN ST. LOUIS.
AS THEIR CITY DEGRADED AND FELL
APART AROUND THEM BECAME DIRTY
AND DANGEROUS OVER THE LAST
DECADE, THEY DID NOT FLEE TO THE
SUBURBS MANY OF THEIR NEIGHBORS
DEAD BUT STAYED IN THEIR HOME.
THEY’VE BEEN IN THE SAME HOME
FOR 32 YEARS.
THEY BUILT IT ENTIRELY SLOWLY
AND PAINSTAKINGLY.
THEY LOVE IT.
ON SUNDAY, THEY SAT ON THEIR
BACKYARD TOGETHER HAVING DINNER.
SUDDENLY AS THEY ATE, A MOB OF
HUNDREDS OF SCREAMING PEOPLE
DESTROYED AND CAME POURING IN
MOVING TOWARD THEM QUICKLY.
THEY WERE TERRIFIED AND WATCHED
AS MOBS LOOTED AND BURNED
CITIZENS AROUND THE COUNTRY.
WAS CLEARLY INTENT ON VIOLENCE,
THEY SAID SO.
WHEN McCLOSKEY TOLD THEM TO
LEAVE, THEY THREATENED TO MURDER
HIM AND HIS WIFE AND THREATENED
TO KILL THE FAMILY’S DOG.
PANICKED, THEY CALLED THE
POLICE, THAN THE CALL THE
NEIGHBORHOOD SECURITY PATROL BUT
NO ONE CAME.
THEY HAD NO CHOICE TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES.
THEY WENT INSIDE AND GOT THERE
YES, LEGALLY REGISTERED FIREARMS
FIREARMS.
IT WORKED.
MET FINALLY BY CITIZENS WHO DARE
DEFEND THEMSELVES, AND THE MOB
RETREATED AND MELTED AWAY, BUT
THE TERROR DID NOT END.
THE SITE OF ORDINARY AMERICANS
STANDING UP FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR HOME ENRAGED AND
IMMEDIATELY PUT THE McCLOSKEY
NAME AND HOME ADDRESS ALL OVER
THE INTERNET.
THREATS POURED IN.
HE SPENT LAST NIGHT BOARDING UP
HIS OFFICE DOWNTOWN, HE HAD NO
CHOICE.
STILL, NO ONE STEPPED FORWARD TO
PROTECT THE McCLOSKEYS, NOT
ONE PERSON.
AMAZINGLY, MISSOURI HAS A
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR, FORMER
SHERIFF CALLED MIKE PARSON, BUT
DID NOT SPEND STATE TROOPERS TO
PROTECT THEM, HE DIDN’T EVEN
CALL THE McCLOSKEYS.
THERE’S A LOT HE COULD HAVE
DONE.
GOOD OF AN THAT AS LONG AS HE
RUNS A STATE, NO CITIZEN WILL BE
PROSECUTED FOR EXERCISING THE
MOST BASIC OF ALL RIGHTS, THE
RIGHT OF SELF-DEFENSE AGAINST
THE MOB.
LET THE GOVERNOR DIDN’T DO THAT.
SO SENSING THEY WERE COMPLETELY
UNDEFENDED, THEY DESCENDED.
ST. LOUIS IS DISTRICT ATTORNEY
ANNOUNCED THAT SHE WAS
CONSIDERING FILING CRIMINAL
CHARGES AGAINST THE McCLOSKEYS
FOR RESISTING THE MOB.
A MOB THAT WAS THREATENING TO
MURDER THEM.
HE VOWED TO "USE THE FULL POWER
OF THE THAT THE POWER TO DEFEND
THEM AGAINST PEOPLE THREATENING
TO KILL THEM, BUT THE FULL POWER
TO CRUSH THEM FOR RESISTING.
THE MEDIA MEANWHILE IMMEDIATELY
SET ABOUT TRYING TO SHOW THE
McCLOSKEYS WERE RACIST.
HERE’S HOW "THE WASHINGTON POST"
FRAMED THE STORY.
AS THE PEACEFUL CROWD OF 500
WALKED ALONG A PRIVATE GATED
STREET, A WHITE COUPLE WHO
EMERGED FROM A MARVEL MANSION
HAD SOMETHING ELSE IN MIND.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AGREED THIS
WAS DEFINITELY A HATE CRIME.
"PRESIDENT TRUMP ON MONDAY
MORNING RETWEETED A VIDEO OF A
WHITE MAN AND WOMAN BRANDISHING
A SEMIAUTOMATIC RIFLE AND A
HANDGUN GOT IT PEACEFUL BACK
PROTESTERS.
ALMOST EVERY WORD ALIVE.
IN FACT, THE MOB WAS NOT BLACK
WHATEVER THAT MEANS THAT IT
DEFINITELY WASN’T PEACEFUL.
WAS MURDEROUS.
NO ONE EXPLAINED WHAT I HAD TO
DO WITH ANYTHING.
A WHITE MAN, A WHITE COUPLE,
OKAY, THEY ARE.
SO WHAT?
WHY IS THAT RELEVANT?
WHY IS IT EVER RELEVANT IN A
SITUATION LIKE THIS?
IT’S NOT.
BUT AGAIN, NO ONE BOTHERED TO
EXPLAIN.
ONLINE, THE DIGITAL ENABLERS
TOOK THE BAIT.
TIME TO HATE THE McCLOSKEYS.
A LONGTIME LIBERTARIAN ACTIVIST
IN WASHINGTON CALLED JERRY
TAYLOR IMMEDIATELY TWEETED THIS
"IF I WERE IN THAT MARCH AND
THESE RACIST LOOTED TECHS WERE
WAVING GUNS AT ME, I’D LIKE TO
THINK I’D RUSH THEM AND BEAT
THEIR BRAINS AND, AND I WOULDN’T
APOLOGIZE FOR IT FOR ONE
SECOND."
JERRY TAYLOR BY BY THE WAY ISN’T
SOME LONE LUNATIC.
HE RUNS A THINK TANK IN
WASHINGTON AND YET HERE WAS
JERRY TAYLOR, LIBERTARIAN IN
GOOD STANDING ENCOURAGING BRUTAL
VIOLENCE AGAINST STRANGERS FOR
DEFENDING THEMSELVES.
NO ONE EVEN SEEMED TO NOTICE,
NOBODY CARED.
THE MESSAGE TO EVERYBODY ELSE
WAS CRYSTAL CLEAR.
THE MOB IS IN CHARGE.
THEIR POWER CANNOT BE CURBED.
DON’T EVEN CONSIDER DEFENDING
YOURSELF ALL BUT SAID THAT OUT
LOUD TODAY, DEMANDED THAT HER
STATE MAKE RACIALLY MOTIVATED
911 CALLS A HATE CRIME, IT’S
ALREADY A CRIME IN THE STATE OF
MICHIGAN’S WHAT WOULD BE THE
PURPOSE OF THIS ORDER?
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER.
FEAR.
THE MOB ONCE THE POWER TO
DESTROY ANYONE WHO WANTS POLICE
PROTECTION FROM MOSTLY PEACEFUL
PROTESTS.
IT’S AN IMPEDIMENT TO THEIR
POWER, SO GRETCHEN WHITMER IS
TRYING TO SWEEP IT AWAY.
YOU CAN SEE EXACTLY WHAT’S
COMING, IT’S OBVIOUS WHAT THEY
ARE PLANNING.
WHAT’S FASCINATING IS THE PEOPLE
DOING THIS AND KNOW IT, THEY
KNOW THE CONSEQUENCES OF THESE
PLANS, AND THEY DON’T PLAN TO
LIVE WITH THOSE CONSEQUENCES.
ON FRIDAY, THE MINNEAPOLIS
CITY COUNCIL VOTED UNANIMOUSLY
TO ABOLISH THEIR CITY’S POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
A NUMBER OF THEM EXPLAIN WHY
THEY WERE VOTING THIS WAY.
WATCH.
>> NOW IS THE TIME FOR US HAS A
CITY TO START PAYING THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN DOING THIS WORK FOR
DECADES THAT NEED TO GET PAID.
ALL THAT MONEY HAS BEEN GOING TO
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT AND WHAT
HAVE WE GOTTEN IN RETURN?
PAIN, TRAUMA, AND HURT.
WE WILL BE TAKING INTERMEDIATE
STEPS TOWARDS ENDING THE MPD
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS.
>> SHOWING UP AS A PERSON THAT
BELIEVES THAT WE SHOULD AND CAN
ABOLISH OUR CURRENT MINNEAPOLIS
POLICE SYSTEM.
>> Tucker: THOSE WERE AWFULLY
EMPHATIC STATEMENTS WHICH MIGHT
BE A GOOD STOMACH EASY TO BE
MISLED BY THEM.
THE MINNEAPOLIS CITY COUNCIL
ISN’T ACTUALLY OPPOSED TO ARMED
PROTECTION, THEY ARE OPPOSED TO
YOU HAVING IT.
THEY ARE OPPOSED TO THE POLICE
PROTECTING YOUR FAMILY AND YOUR
HOMES.
BUT THEY ARE NOT OPPOSED TO
PROTECTING THEMSELVES, AND
THAT’S WHY THE THREE MINNEAPOLIS
CITY COUNCILMAN YOU JUST SAW
REQUESTED AND RECEIVED
TAXPAYER-FUNDED SECURITY GUARDS.